[Music]
on this Sunday night a hockey player
turns himself in walking into an Ontario
Police Station the former NHL faces
charges over sexual assault allegations
it'll be at least a year before we get
to a trial at least a year what his
legal team says about his
innocence the United Nations plea for
Aid suspension of Aid is in line with
the Israeli plans for the force
evacuation of our people from Gaza into
Egypt why its Agency for Palestinians is
still losing funding after firing 12
staff members a final goodbye to Ed
broadband and we hope that his memory
will help guide us to a more Equitable
Society celebrating The Life and Legacy
of a giant of Canada's new Democratic
party and pioneering IVF pregnancy we
actually achieved what we worked for for
years the major advance in fertility
that could save a nearly extinct Rhino
species global national with faren Asser
reporting tonight M Gara good evening
and thanks for joining us the first
hockey player accused in the alleged
group sexual assault of a young woman in
London Ontario has turned himself into
police lawyers for Alex formenton who
played on Canada's World Junior Team in
2018 accompanied him into the London
Police Station today they confirm
formenton and several other players are
being charged Mike tray has more on what
we learned today and what happens next
in this high-profile case decked out in
a gray jacket with white sneakers his
lawyers on either side of him former NHL
player Alex formenton turned himself in
at London Police Headquarters where his
legal team confirmed he and several
other players were charged in relation
to an alleged sexual assault by members
of Canada's 2018 World Junior Team
formenton left with his lawyers less
than 2 hours later in a statement for
menon's legal team said the London
Police have charged several players
including Alex formenton in connection
with an accusation made in 2018 Alex
will vigorously defend his innocence and
ask that people not rush to judgment
without hearing all of the evidence
according to a report by the globe in
mail five members of Canada's World
Junior Team were told to surrender to
police four current NHL players who were
also on that 2018 junior team were given
indefinite lead as announced by their
teams this week although there is no
confirmation they are related to the
globe report lawyers for Philadelphia
Flyers goly Carter Hart and Dylan Dubay
of the Calgary Flames have previously
said their clients did not engage in any
wrongdoing Cal foot and Michael McLoud
of the New Jersey Devils also left their
team foot has also publicly denied being
involved news of the alleged assault
first broke in May 2022 when TSN
reported Hockey Canada had settled a
civil lawsuit with the complainant known
as em who was 20 years old at the time
she told police about an alleged sexual
assault by a group of junior hockey
players it'll be at least a year before
we get to a trial at least a year if not
longer and DNE Gilbert who teaches a
sexual assault law says the timeline of
this case could drag on even more if the
accused are tried separately and the
case she says comes down to the question
of consent a person cannot consent
unless they're capable of consenting
that's directly in the law so capable of
consent means being able to express
affirmative consent and so we have very
strong laws only Yes means yes so
passivity doesn't mean yes silenced
doesn't mean yes um a failure to get up
and leave does not mean yes uh you know
they needed to have from her affirmative
outright consent London Police have not
commented on the case saying they
anticipate holding a press conference on
February 5th m Global News
Toronto three US service members have
been killed and at least 25 others
injured in a drone attack on a small us
Outpost in Jordan overnight it marks the
first time US troops have been killed by
enemy fire in the Middle East since the
October 7th Hamas attacks the killing of
three Americans is considered a
significant escalation there remain
fears the Israel Gaza War could trigger
a wider mid East conflict according to
us command a drone struck an American
base in Northeast Jordan identified by
us officials as Tower 22 the base is
along the Syrian border and is used by
US troops to assist Jordanian forces but
a spokesperson for Jordan's government
says the Drone strike targeted the US
alamp military base located inside Syria
no group has claimed responsibility but
in a statement US President Joe Biden
said it was carried out by radical Iran
B militant groups operating in Syria and
Iraq and that the US will hold all those
responsible to account the US President
also spoke about the attack late
today we had a tough day last
night
e the broader conflict shows little sign
of de-escalating anytime soon
iran-backed houthi Rebels are also
targeting ships linked to Israel and the
West in the Red Sea
even firing drones at a US warship and a
UK destroyer in recent days and
divisions between Israel and the United
Nations are growing by the day un
Secretary General Antonio gutterz is
pleading with nine countries to restore
funding for the un's relief agency in
Gaza Canada and the US and other Western
allies suspended funding after Israel
alleged 12 agency staff members were
involved in the October 7th Hamas
attacks Redmond Shannon reports
s thousands of gazin on the Move further
south away from can Yunis which is
surrounded by Israeli forces they are
fearing for their lives and fearing the
little Aid that is getting through could
dry
up what we are going through right now
is not a war from Israel it is a war
between the world against us she is
referring to the decision of nine
countries including Canada and the US to
Halt Aid to unra the un's relief agency
in Gaza that after Israel alleged 12
unrest staff members were involved in
the October 7th attacks on Israel the UN
has ordered an investigation and has
fired accused staff but its Secretary
General appealed to donor countries
saying 2 million gazin rely on critical
Aid in a statement Antonio gues said the
apparent alleged Act acts of these staff
members must have consequences but the
tens of thousands who work for unra
should not be penalized the dire needs
of the desperate populations they serve
must be met the Palestinian prime
minister in the West Bank says the
threat to Gaz and Aid comes just as the
international court of justice ordered
Israel to do more to help civilians in
Gaza suspension of Aid is in line with
the Israeli plans for the force
evacuation of our people from Gaza into
Egypt at one of the main Crossings
between Israel and Gaza Israeli
protesters attempted to block Aid
deliveries getting in giving Kamas food
water and fuel is something that allows
the war to continue on Sunday Israel
held talks with the US katar and Egypt
to try and negotiate the release of the
approximately 100 remaining hostages
held by Hamas the office of Israeli
Prime Minister benj Benjamin Netanyahu
described the meeting as constructive
but said meaningful gaps remain it said
talks will continue in the coming days
Neu Redmond Shannon in London thanks
Redmond Global Affairs Canada has
confirmed a Palestinian Canadian man has
gone missing in Gaza Mansour Schuman was
reportedly in Gaza working as part of a
team documenting the ongoing
humanitarian efforts during the Israel
Hamas war and claims of genocide in
statement Global Affairs says it
continues to monitor the situation
closely and is in direct contact with
family members according to reports
Mansour Schuman is believed to have been
abducted while moving through a safe
passage between Han Yunis and Rafa
family members say they last heard from
Schuman on January
21st in Ottawa political leaders
gathered to say their final goodbyes to
Ed Broadbent at the state funeral for
the highly respected former NDP leader
[Music]
at a ceremony usually reserved for prime
ministers cabinet ministers and Governor
generals colleagues and political Rivals
joined forces to pay their respects to
the new democrat at one point Ed
Broadbent was considered to be the
country's most popular politician he
served Canadians for nearly 24 years in
Parliament McKenzie gray has more on
today's ceremony and how Broadbent is
being remembered
[Music]
the line stretched around the block
where Canadians of all political Stripes
came to honor Ed Broadbent he was a
tireless campaigner for social justice
and Canada is significantly better for
his years of service and we reject that
perspective of this country Broadbent
best remembered for leading the NDP for
14 years and through four consecutive
elections the most successful 1988 when
the of their best showing to date
winning 43 seats but for many new
Democrats including Broadbent that
result felt like a loss well the rest of
us have lots of pleasure these kids are
suffering in the year before the
election the NDP had topped the polls
for their first time in history and
Broadband himself was more popular than
both Brian Mo Rooney and John Turner but
that didn't translate into more seats we
thought going into the 88 campaign
anyway and I certainly thought that this
could bring us into the official oppos
position the NDP stayed in third place
leading Broadband to quit a year later
but not before the then prime minister
made a unique pitch I offered him an
appointment to the
Senate and he said the
Senate God I can't go there uh Brian
that's his dullest bloody dishwater
nothing ever happens there Broadbent
skipped the Senate but continue to push
for solutions to the issu he championed
in Parliament income inequality women's
rights and child poverty guess who's
back he's back who's back is back but
the Allure of politics pulled him back
in this campaign ad from 2004 showed a
lighter side of broadband who handily
won a seed in Ottawa center where he
served an additional two years he was a
remarkably civil and friendly man civil
and friendly to his political opponents
as well as to his colleagues as an elder
Statesman in the NDP he helped negotiate
the failed 2008 coalition government
founded the leaning Think Tank the
Broadband Institute and was a regular
Confidant and campaigner for NDP leaders
we will never forget
him and Ed we won't let you
down and you're still who I want to be
when I grow
up inspiration that will continue to
live on Ed Broadbent was 87 McKenzie
gray Global News
Ottawa tomorrow Federal MPS returned to
the House of Commons for the first time
since the winter break the first order
of business the highly anticipated
public inquiry into foreign interference
which will hold its first day of public
hearings our chief political
correspondent David Aken is keeping a
close eye on what's ahead David what are
you looking for as things get underway
tomorrow well let's start off with the
work of the MPS first the governing
liberals really have only one mission in
front of them and that is to reverse
some of these terrible polling numbers
and to do that they are going to have to
show Canadians they can and are doing
something to improve housing
affordability and lower the cost of
living that's going to be a pretty tall
order now the conservatives under their
leader Pierre POV start the year Riding
High in the polls and they are going to
want to maintain that momentum and one
way they might do that is rolling out a
series of announcements of so-called
star candidates for the next election in
fact they did that last week when
indigenous leader and former BC cabinet
minister Ellis Ross said that he would
run under pv's Banner now jug meet Singh
and the NDP they wrapped up their caucus
meetings in Edmonton last week with the
vow to press for more progress on issues
that were at the core of that confidence
and Supply agreement that the NDP signed
with the Liberals now if the NDP do not
see enough progress on housing National
dental care National pharmacare the
question is will they pull their support
for the minority liberals Quebec voters
are unique in the country in that they
rank progress on climate change highest
on their list of priorities higher in
fact in housing affordability so look
for the block kqu MPS to respond to that
and to continue to push the Liberals to
be as green as they can be meanwhile the
public inquiry into foreign interference
gets underway here tomorrow it is going
to focus on allegations of interference
in our politics by China Russia India
and Iran now it's going to be mostly
academics on the stand to begin but
Public Safety Minister Dominic LeBlanc
is slau it in for Friday so a busy week
ahead indeed David aen in Ottawa thanks
so much for that David cracking down on
the influence of sports betting coming
up the concerns over advertising and its
impact on
youth Canadians who watch sports are
used to seeing plenty of betting ads
during games and on social media today
it's easier than ever to throw money on
a wide range of sporting events critics
worry young people see Sports gambling
is just another part of the game and as
Shawn preville reports they want the
federal government to take action it's
difficult not to turn on a hockey game
or search scores online without seeing
an ad on how to bet for your favorite
team or athlete but former Olympian
Bruce kid is warning with how many
commercials there are there's a risk to
youth even with a legal gambling age in
Canada and we see the ads grooming
Children and Youth to become lifelong
betters when online sports betting
became legal in Canada in 2021 the
floodgates opened for ads psychology
Professor Steve Jordan says it's
becoming normalized when children kind
of see this connection between the two
well now if they love sport they just
naturally do that next step of gambling
he adds with athletes and celebrities
that kids admire often featured it may
add to the influence of these
commercials Ontario is cracking down on
this most of these public figures won't
be able to appear in online gambling ads
starting February 28th and while the
federal government isn't considering
something similar yet if passed a bill
in the Senate could see Ottawa develop a
framework including how to regulate and
possibly restrict sports betting ads
Jordan says restrictions are helpful but
a full ban is still needed by not
marketing it we're we're not telling
people they can't do it but we're at
least letting them know hey there's
danger the Canadian gaming association's
Paul Burns notes while gambling
addiction does exist he disagrees with
comparing it to something like smoking
it's not the same product it's not the
same and it's not something you can
compare to he says with sports betting
ads there's wide ranging measures in
place so games can still be available to
all ages everybody has been leaning in
to Contin to make sure they're getting
it right no one wants to Target miners
but for kid a full ban could make an
impact because of what he says betting
ads du to sport it disembodies sport it
removes sport as a team game it removes
sport as a community cultural activity
Sean preville
news ahead excitement and environmental
concerns as the world's largest cruise
ship begins its maiden
[Music]
voyage that is the famous Mona Lisa
painting inside the Lou in Paris
splashed with soup by climate activist
today demanding better protections for
the environment and sustainable Food
Systems it's not the first time Da
Vinci's Masterpiece has been covered in
food a similar protest smothered the
glass barrier in cream back in
2022 in Miami there was Fanfare on the
water Saturday as the world's largest
cruise ship set sail for its maiden
voyage capable of carrying nearly 10,000
people and measuring about
365 m in length there's no shortage of
leisure aboard the multi-billion dollar
icon of the Seas though there are
concerns about what environmental impact
this colossal vessel is leaving behind
Julia Foy has
more it's just wow it the wow factor was
definitely there when you uh boarded the
ship Roy Rosales is one of 7600
passengers aboard the Royal Caribbean's
icon of the Seas a mega ship that's the
largest cruise liner in the world I
think the other ships now are going to
be tugboats compared to this ship based
out of Miami the icon bows 20 stories
water slot Ides theaters an ice rink and
40 places to eat Travel Experts say it's
set on attracting a younger
demographic after Co it was the last to
come back so it's been cheaper than
other types of Travel Land packages and
hotel packages and so that is enticing
to
someone but not everyone is cheering the
big boat on it runs on liquefied natural
gas which burns cleaner than many Marine
fuels but Environmental groups say it
can also releasee methane gas the moment
that you start using LG as a marine fuel
including in cruise ships you actually
start to emit more greenhouse gas
emissions than if you had done nothing
and continued to run on the fuels that
we're using today hopefully the icon of
the sea will be one of the last LG ships
at
because methane fracking these are not
climate Solutions however Royal
Caribbean believes it is the right fuel
to help transition to cleaner options
sustain ability is a important part of
our journey to destination Net Zero in
the future and LG is one part of that
step forward on that Journey for now the
passengers are just enjoying the sale
you can go on the ship and you can go to
other cities and the cities are a bonus
but really the ship is is is the
destination Julia Foy Global News
Vancouver saving the northern White
Rhino knacks the New Hope For This
endangered
species the northern White Rhino is said
to be the world's most critically
endangered animal only two are known to
be alive but this month scientists
trying to save them from Extinction made
a big step forward it took 13 tries but
they finally managed to impregnate a
rhino using invitro fertilization as
Heidi petrac explains what happens next
will determine the fate of the
species
when the last male Northern White Rhino
Sudan died in 2018 the animal sperm was
saved and the clock started ticking the
remaining members of the species two
females are unable to carry a pregnancy
to term we really made impossible
possible scientists have announced a
breakthrough at a press conference in
Berlin after they used invitro
fertilization to impregnate a surrogate
the southern white Rhino's 70-day
pregnancy they say proved the concept
works is kind of roller coaster because
it's a Sweet Bitter Symphony uh we we
actually achieved what we worked for for
years and we're extremely happy about
that but tragically the female and her
embryo died of an unrelated bacterial
infection even so the scientists call it
a success they intend to repeat the
procedure next time with a northern
White Rhino embryo created in a lab
whatever it takes what whatever humanly
possible to make sure that these animals
do not uh disappear from the face of the
Earth Northern white rhinos once roamed
freely in East and Central Africa but
persistent poaching for their horns sold
illegally for thousands of dollars
brought the species to this precipice
here we have a potential Lifeline this
conservation expert says boosting the
populations of endangered species is
only part of the solution what it now
needs is it needs this broader course of
planning to be able to bring the species
into a situation where it has a chance
to establish itself in the
wild that means protecting both the
animals and the habitat they need to
survive the Rhino team hopes to see
Northern White Rhino calves born by
surrogate within 3 years as they race to
prevent its permanent Extinction Heidi
pic Global News
Halifax and that is global national for
this Sunday night I'm NE ARA tonight's
your Canada is Harrison Hot Springs
British Columbia thanks so much for
watching have a great
night